[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by Buffy
check out the breeze a comforter made
entirely from 100% eucalyptus fiber to
regulate temperature and keep it cool
and comfortable all night long for $20
off your Buffy comfort or visit Buffy CO
and enter code congrats congratulations
is also brought to you by cash app
[Music]
what's up guys
San Diego I'm coming ticket to Chris
D'Elia calm also San Jose and Las Vegas
tickets at Crystal e.com hmm this is
some some episode of congratulations and
we're still here in Albuquerque and it's
great and you know what we're blending
in people I [ __ ] you know I'm a local
at this point dude you can't tell me I'm
not from [ __ ] Albuquerque I've been
here two weeks and I gotta say I thought
it was gonna be much I thought I thought
I was gonna be what do you call it a
homesick there's the thing that a mind
does I think if you're if you're like I
could go away for five days or two weeks
or a month as long as I know how long
I'm going away for you know like if I go
that you know I noticed it on the road
if I have to two nights to do if I got a
night in New York and a night in New
Jersey and if I know that this is all I
got
then that's as long as I can stay but if
I'm going on a ten-day vacation and
that's what I got by the way a ten-day
vacation is way worse than going for two
days of work because I don't want to be
I don't to be relaxing that long I can't
do it do it
III dude I was thinking about I don't I
don't somebody asked me the other day on
set like what when he cuz I was talking
about how I haven't done stand-up in 11
this is the 12th day consecutively I
haven't done stand-up and that's the
longest I've ever gone since I started
my stand-up career I
ever went longer than that in 13 years
and somebody was like well you don't
take a vacation and I was like I don't
think I ever took a vacation I don't
think I've ever taken a vacation I went
to Hawaii once with my ex but I took
like two I did two shows I think she was
probably secretly mad about that who
knows man but chicks are always secretly
mad you know if you're with the chick
she's secretly mad I got news for you if
you want to know if you're in a
relationship is there a girl around you
that's secretly mad that's your
girlfriend it's all good oh I'm
tightening this up dude I like to stand
better I'm live on my app you can do you
can go out download my app to see the if
you subscribe to my pot to my app then
you can see me do the first 10 minutes
or 12 whatever minutes of the podcast
before anyone else anyway dude this is
Albuquerque it's hotter than [ __ ] you
know what it wasn't so hot actually
yesterday and it was nice as [ __ ] and it
was raining it thundered a little foetus
or I don't know it a thunderstorm out of
nowhere in the sky
you know what Albuquerque does right for
real the sky and you know I've lived in
like New Jersey I lived in LA and
there's thunderstorms in New Jersey but
dude in Albuquerque
it's like it'll you'll see that
lightning that it's like really far away
and it'll just like light up the whole
sky and then it'll crap and then and
then it'll [ __ ] illuminate from the
ground it's amazing dude the clouds they
got our different clouds man I know it's
the same clouds you see but they're
different clouds
dude the LA skies terrible that likes
guys terrible it's all smoggy and [ __ ]
but what have I done I I was in we've
been shooting shotguns for the for the
first time I shot a pistol and an m4 I
think that was what it was that was what
the Navy SEALs guys were telling me the
first day I was just like so it's weird
to pick up like a killing machine you
know like something that's made for
killing that's what was in my head and
then the second day I was like I felt
like Ron wick I felt like I was like
John wicks brother I was like I got this
[ __ ] well the the [ __ ] the empty
rounds will fly out and hit your face
and that shit's hot like summer on your
face do
um and that's like you know I was just
thinking about like okay like you hit
targets first of all we don't have to
hit targets cuz we're in a movie you
know what I'm talking about so you're
doing that and you got the gun and then
you and then and then you got it and
then yeah it doesn't really matter and
the first time I was doing I was like
trying hit the target and I was like oh
I don't need to hit the [ __ ] target
it'll cut and I'll hit the target
it'll edit it into me hitting the car I
was like I got a concentrate just on
like drawing and [ __ ] like that and so I
was draw so I would I would do that and
I would fire it and I don't know where I
was going with this but uh so I really
was trying to do my [ __ ] I don't know
do you know what it actually has been
happening I've been looking at my
[ __ ] phone too long and it makes my
brain dead it makes my brain like do it
before phones I would think of stuff in
the world like I'd be like oh this is
like that that's like this it would make
me funny right now I just stare at
[ __ ] Instagram or Twitter or whatever
and I just feel like a piece of [ __ ]
well my apps not working I think
technical difficulties let me let me
start it over the app just the app maybe
this works yeah but I don't know but
like I used to think of [ __ ] phones
[ __ ] me up I used to think of [ __ ] and
now I don't think of [ __ ] like I was
just as Starbucks and I I noticed
something that was funny at Starbucks
Starbucks like when I was at Starbucks
this dude these two dudes walk in and
there were s Albuquerque like one guy
came in and had like tattoos all over
and it was real skinny if you're skinny
and you got tattoos all over here from
Albuquerque and so he was like he was
chillin with his other buddy and his
other brother but he looked like him if
he was on if he was on like a workout
plan like he's a little healthier that
they were sitting down and I wasn't
looking behind me but they were talking
and and all I kept hearing was this dude
who was like a a dog a dog if of all the
other guys name was Chris so gay Chris
he's like they'd take a picture they
take a picture I mean dog
and then Chris took a better just in
Chris leg like that and then the guy was
like nah man come on man I don't like a
picture like that
and he was like take it take a different
picture of me dawg and Chris was like
nah bro you got to do it like this he
was like nah dawg they took another
picture say hey man come on man don't
take a picture like that I hate pictures
like that that's what he was saying and
I was like what the [ __ ] kind of
pictures would like how they were in a
Starbucks like what kind of [ __ ]
picture is he taking I wanted to turn
around so bad but I didn't want them to
be like eh what the [ __ ] are you looking
at bro you're not from here so and I was
like thinking about how that was funny
you know and I was like ah dude I could
maybe make a bit about that and then I
just started looking at my phone forgot
no bit there will be no bit about that
not even on my podcast I'm talking about
on stage that's not gonna be new
material now because a [ __ ] Instagram
is not working that's annoying I have
this app that works some a lot and they
just [ __ ] keep [ __ ] it up they
keep [ __ ] texting me and [ __ ]
whatever it doesn't matter so now I
don't know and also I also I was in the
same Starbucks and this guy comes up to
me he's like hey man I really like your
hair and as I god thanks and he says
yeah I always wanted curly hair like
that and I said oh yeah and he said yeah
guy had long [ __ ] Johnny Depp here
that was like silver and [ __ ] and then
just walked out didn't even get a coffee
it's like he came to just look for
somebody with cool hair and then [ __ ]
walked out walked into Starbucks was
homeless maybe not maybe people are
homeless or maybe they're from
Albuquerque I don't know you know and
went to some you know local restaurants
and [ __ ] and no matter what I do - it's
like the wrong thing like I'll post
something I'll make in front of [ __ ] I'm
making fun of [ __ ] on my Instagram and
then somebody will write me Oh bro
you're not even go to the right place
man you make fun Albuquerque but there's
a lot of cool places and I'll go to
another place and then sorry oh you
gotta go to this other place then I go
to that place nah bro you gotta cut the
[ __ ] up I'll just do whatever you know
it'll be fine a place is cool it's not
cool if you're there for two weeks and
you're bored of [ __ ] then that's how it
is hopefully this doesn't make the news
but it's fine dude it's not it's not
it's
not bad it's not a bad place it's
actually the people are really nice and
know you know what's really cool about
Albuquerque is they don't [ __ ] bother
you too much like people aren't in your
face like everywhere else I go there
more in there more like like dude I'll
tell you what in Albuquerque I'm the
least famous guy nobody nobody can I get
a picture so only a very very rarely
everywhere else I go can I get a picture
tiger picture maybe it's the news thing
maybe they're [ __ ] try to boycott me
I don't know but um yeah I don't know
Albuquerque is a lot of mud huts and
it's got this own like New Mexico's got
like it's so weird how it goes over like
from the eat from the west coast
California the style of California is
just kind of whatever just doesn't
really have crazy style then you get
over to [ __ ] like Arizona and it's
got this obvious kind of like sort of
like I guess like like I don't even have
to scar like this Aztec e'en Indian type
[ __ ] style and then you get over to
New Mexico and it's like you're just
there pretty much it's like got this
like Mexican sort of like really like
there's no mistaking this artwork and it
now it's pretty it's always a just like
tan and [ __ ] brown and [ __ ] and then
you see that Sun with the with the
[ __ ] like the thing on the like slate
that [ __ ] is everywhere like the
Albuquerque symbol I've never seen a
symbol more in a place than Albuquerque
people have it on the back of their neck
they get a tattooed dude Albuquerque
here's the other thing too and I'm and
I'm not even knocking it but you guys oh
my buddy on the on the on the show on
that we're doing Omari Hardwick he's on
power he's on this movie he got a
[ __ ] dope tattoo I might go to the
tattoo place but most of the tattoos in
the Albuquerque you look like you were
just bored and went to go get the tattoo
and were like yeah okay I guess and so
many Albuquerque sons with the [ __ ]
what he called it on the same thing on
the license plate but anyway and then
after Santa Santa Fe after New Mexico
what's after New Mexico [ __ ] Texas
what's to the east that's it
and then it's like kind of gone it's
sort of gone I mean Texas is kind of
more cowboy [ __ ] and then it's gone
after Texas is just like there's no like
I guess it's in fluid from Mexico I
guess I don't know I could google it but
I'm not gonna you know so just that's
how it is we learned um so yeah I went
to the Starbucks I don't know Starbucks
still tastes like a [ __ ] back of a
cow's mouth I've had some other cool
coffee shops that are cool but also
they're not that good people are like
you got to go this when I go to that one
it's not that good also what's up with
like [ __ ] if it's not painted Brown
it's painted white and it's so sunny
that I needed to get glasses I got these
[ __ ] sunglasses from sunglass hut I
drove to the mall to do it and I was
like I got it I give up I was like I
literally like I was I was like I give
up dude I [ __ ] it's too bright I got
to Albuquerque I was like it doesn't
really matter I don't need to get
sunglasses I could just walk around my
opener never has sunglasses he's always
just kind of squinting I was like I
could do it bro is brighter here did you
know that it's [ __ ] brighter here so
I had to go to the mall okay by the way
go to this mall every other store is a
shoe store now here's the deal every
other stores this shoe store but also I
walk in as soon as I go there's a walk
in there's a kiosk of sunglass hut so
it's like okay cool so I say hey man do
you have any like Ray Bans those are the
kinds I like I was like I'm just gonna
[ __ ] get it and he was like ah we
don't have the kind you want he said I
said oh but aren't there other isn't
there like another sunglass hut here in
the mall and it goes like this there's
four hat
hey there's four sunglass huts in the
[ __ ] mall in Albuquerque in the
Coronado mall you don't need for you
need one just take the [ __ ] kiosks
out and put them all in the one goddamn
one you can seriously do that economy of
glasses economy of lenses put the
[ __ ]
glasses in the kiosk why am i peeking
I'm peeking oh I'm peeking put the
sunglass yeah okay that's better
ha I guess it sounds like maybe I'm it's
gonna be a rough one so that's what it
is here you want to hear it you got a
good news for me
why okay alright anyway uh we did we
went to sunglass hut I went to sunglass
hut by myself and I got the [ __ ]
glasses and it's all good this is so
[ __ ] boring what am I doing here I
don't I don't you know what though I
just feel like you're you know some pod
casts are gonna be good and some are
gonna be [ __ ] boring I listen to I
listen to some other guy some other
podcasts and by the way I listen to some
other podcasts and they're [ __ ]
boring as [ __ ] too
except for some of them are [ __ ]
really interesting this one will never
be really interesting it'll just be kind
of funny sometimes how about the lady
that [ __ ] drove through the the
jack-in-the-box thing or whatever it was
and and and they said hey it'll be
[ __ ] 1950 or whatever and she said
this one's on God and she drove away did
you hear about that yeah she goes this
one's on God like gods paying for it hey
going to hell hey you're going to hell
dude that's the first person should that
should be in line for hell you can't use
God to get free [ __ ] burgers I'm
gonna do that but so many people hit me
up too cuz the last episode was called
[ __ ] take it up with Christ
people were like ah she shoulda said
take it up with Christ this one's on God
you could say that right when you bust
nuts this one's on God
[ __ ] whatever dude I wake up every
time I wake up in Albuquerque my nose is
so dry and I go to the bathroom to get
tissues this is how dumb I am dude every
morning I wake up at like whenever
before you really wake up you know how
you wake up you do the pre wake up
before you really wake up which is
annoying as [ __ ] your body just can't
stay awake for eight hours who sleeps
for eight hours straight I've done that
maybe if I take a nyquil
but like I'll sleep and then wake up and
then sleep and then wake up and when I
wake up my nose is drier than the Sahara
okay
so then I'll get up and every time I
think man I really should just bring the
tissues over to the bedroom to the bed I
go I get the tissues I blow my nose and
I don't burn anything now I'll just
it'll be fine
and then I go back in bed and then I
don't bring the [ __ ] tissues and then
I wake up again in an hour and I think I
really gotta bring these tissues back
and then I don't and I go to the [ __ ]
bathroom and then I come back and I'm
doing [ __ ] calisthenics and when I
can just be [ __ ] grabbing the tissue
and blow my nose and I don't do that
[ __ ] I don't know what it is it's like I
don't want to succeed in my life when it
comes to [ __ ] normal [ __ ] I want it
to make it the hardest way possible and
I don't know why maybe it's cuz my life
is easier good but I [ __ ] uh you know
it's so dried that I have to blow my
nose I have to do a few blow nose blows
before I actually get the [ __ ] out you
know what I'm talking about and it's
horrible and then I take all the tissues
and I throw them on the so I did it last
night I brought that didn't thing the
tissue box and I brought the tissues and
I would blow my nose and I put it next
to my bed I just drop them there and
then they I was like I gotta clean this
up because it looks like I [ __ ]
jerked off and I just had the tissues
next to my bed no cleaning these good oh
so sorry you jerked off also at the
hotel I'm staying at they [ __ ] knock
on the door before 9 a.m.
to clean the room what the [ __ ] Who am I
Steve Jobs I'm not waking up then with a
[ __ ] wakes up at before and in a hotel
is what I'm saying like in your daily
life
get you gotta wake up at [ __ ] 7:00
sometimes or 6:00 to work out and then
go to work but in a hotel dude start the
[ __ ] at 10:30 that's it
start at 10:30 make sure everyone's out
and it's also annoying because when I
[ __ ] wake up but I go and I open the
door I'm like hey and I'm like y'all I'm
still sleeping or like okay as like but
come back later and then they don't it's
like well [ __ ] you if you're not gonna
if you're gonna burn daylight you don't
get your room cleaned and then I went
downstairs and I was like hey I need
more body wash it give you like a little
[ __ ] ass symbol of it you know hotels
cuz they don't want you to it's like
they don't want you to waste it but it's
more like they don't want you to use it
they're like God will give them a little
bit and it's almost not enough for my
whole body you know my [ __ ] mountain
ride got a mountain range on my back how
the [ __ ] am I supposed to wash these
this [ __ ] Jim saying I've got shoulders
that go on until next Thursday and you
want me to wash with a little thimble
what why I'm sorry but what and so I
went down I said hey can I get some body
wash and I go like this I look at the
front desk and I go like this because
I'm a gesture to my [ __ ] mountain
range and she's like sure and then when
I got up next time I got up there was a
[ __ ] bag of them like a [ __ ] you bag
did I love that [ __ ] man
loving it loving it but as hot as [ __ ]
you know
did you see [ __ ] army hammer how he
let his kid suck his toe and everyone
went nuts thought it was Armageddon dude
I don't care it doesn't matter I
couldn't believe it is it this by the
way is it like do people think that like
suck it on a toe is a sexual thing I it
was that what it was it was like four
seconds the kid was just sucking on army
hammers till he see his own kid and he
was like he's been doing this for like
an hour
obviously joking and the internet
flipped out dude his name was trending
over 6,000 times you know what I did I
followed him I'm [ __ ] Instagram cuz
that's what you get you get a follow
dude that shit's funny as hell what is
it cuz it's a sexual thing dude if my
kid sucks my toe I go what the [ __ ] are
you doing and I film it that's what I do
I'm team army hammer bro so I followed
him on instagram because that's what you
get when you're a [ __ ] pro on
Instagram he's a pro on Instagram
filming some [ __ ] and daily life that
people want to say people were like oh
no I'm so bummed I looked at it it's so
gross no it's not dude AB although I
think that here's the thing if you think
it's gross you think of feed as a sexual
thing cuz why is it gross who cares what
if the kid was sucking on his finger
what's the difference it doesn't matter
it's [ __ ] toast dude and I got a
buddy who's that got like a foot fetish
like a serious one and that's weirdest
[ __ ] he's a big comedian and he loves
feet and I would never tell you who that
is cuz I'm cuz I'm loyal but it I'll
tell you why it's not one of those
stories that ends with and that man is
me it's not me I don't get it and then
also some people are like ill feet like
go [ __ ] yourself look down you got him
but this guy loves feet you ever see
like feet jobs on the Internet
like you ever watch more than 2 seconds
of it you know how hard it is it's
harder to rent the [ __ ] car
you're like or it's harder than renting
a car you let there like like this you
know don't use anything to jerk anything
off unless it's got a thumb with it
[ __ ] knees all out and [ __ ] so not
sexy
girlf joking you off with feet hey yeah
if you can't use one then it doesn't
work you know you gotta use both because
you don't have thumbs
that's weird although I would like to be
in a feet though it would be cool to be
in two feet sexually because then you
could be like oh I got another thing
that's like people like I wish I was in
the feet it's weird but like I wish I
had more things I was into sexually I
got pretty much regular [ __ ] like I like
to be kind of dominant but then also
that's pretty much it you do three
positions I've been over this dude you
do missionary you do doggy style and
then you do the girl on top but you
don't do also if you're a guy on guy I'm
you know I've never done guy on guy I'm
not gay but like if I kind of wish I was
so I can make those rules too because if
I make those rules as a straight man
people gonna get mad but here's the
rules anyway okay get mad if you want
you only do doggy that's it
you don't do it you don't face each
other until I was about thirty I didn't
think about like I thought like oh you
just do regular you just do doggy gay
guys just do doggy but I was like you
don't have to I go [ __ ] you could do
like face to face but then it but then
you're having sex with the guy and the
other guys the other guy's looking at
you it unplugged and then the other guys
it's okay it unplugged that thing and
then the other guys looking at you but
then he but then his his dick is
flopping all around you know I didn't
think about the other guy's dick when
you're having sex it's okay
it just went a little quieter that's all
what
am i keeping going yeah I can hear
myself I never thought about the other
guy's dick in gay sex do you know I'm
saying you have a home for your penis if
you're the giver but the other guy's
penis is kind of more like like he's
looking for a gate at the airport I'm
saying you've never thought about that
if you're a straight dude you don't
really think about this stuff but I do
because you have to I think I have to
think about all the things to make all
the rules the other guy's dick is
looking for a gate at the airport that's
what he's doing and then if he's his
turn to give he's like up found we're
boarding and the other guys like I've
arrived at my destination I wish I was
into all the stuff I wish I was gay I
wish I was well as long as it's legal
you're not I'm talking about the more
the better dude the more busting the
better right that's how it is that's my
mayor platform running for mayor
platform that's my pet phone run for
mayor that we had these Navy guy maybe
SEALs training us to how to shoot the
guns and [ __ ] I'd always try to like
make people laugh like that's my thing
like to like you know I feel like like
in my head it's like breaking someone
like if I can make them laugh then it's
like okay good then we're good and I can
like communicate with the person now
which is probably the most [ __ ] up
thing if I really think about it but I
was you know making these little jokes
here and there and then Navy SEALs guys
were not laughing because they they just
[ __ ] I probably killed 40 guys you
know what do you laugh at if you've
killed 40 guys so I was like I'm just
not even gonna try with them and then
people were going around the room saying
like what are you gonna do this weekend
you're in Albuquerque what he gonna do
you got two days off and I just said I
you know I decided I'm gonna run for
mayor of Albuquerque and the [ __ ]
Navy SEAL dude laughed hard and I was
like oh that's what broke him and I was
into it and then I was friends with the
Navy SEAL guy the Navy SEAL guy
afterwards was like he brought it up
again he was like so what do you think
is gonna be like your platform that you
run on
Wow you wanted to play yeah and so I
said to him well you know I'm really
religious so and he started laughing
again more oh that shit's the kind of
[ __ ] that makes me feel bonkers good
dude
he would ask me more my performance I
wanted to pleadin wanted to play more
and I was like we're doing it dude I
love making people laugh dude that's it
man that's it that's all I ever wanted
to do man that's all I ever wanted to do
I heard my dad on the podcast the other
day and he said that's all I ever wanted
to do and I was like oh [ __ ] he's right
it is all I ever wanted to do
so I'm anyway I'm a big army hammer fan
after all that [ __ ] because he let his
kids suck his towel for a fun fun goof
[Laughter]
man sex is weird huh
my favorite [ __ ] too is like I saw who
the [ __ ] was it I saw a girl on on
Twitter
she's always popping up in my [ __ ] like
people either respond to her or
something I can't remember a [ __ ]
name I think she follows me but she was
like but she was like she just is
gangster on her Twitter [ __ ] what is it
I don't remember and it was like all
like people just because Twitter is like
the Wild West like Instagram you can
barely post a [ __ ] well I mean you
can't post a nipple you know some of
these Co watches ads they're basically
het porn but like you know these girls
would be like Co watches and they'll
have their watch like this and their
nipple they're just like it'll be like
that [ __ ] ping pong thing where the in
South Park where the ping pong ball
keeps coming either I don't know the
[ __ ] but it's like Co watches on
Instagram and it's like scientists sign
to use my code 20% off Co watches and
we're like where's the co watch it's
coming out of
it's coming out of her I get it and but
this girl's gangster like because on
Instagram Riley read is what it is
that's what that's hurt her that's her
name and and she and I was and I looked
at her Twitter and it's like gangster
like these poor I don't know if I don't
really I haven't seen many porn stars on
Twitter but this one I should look at
more to see if they're all like this but
this one was and I'm not trying to be
like holier than thou I watched porn I'm
not I'm not trying to be like ooh I get
all the things that porn does I go on
pornhub you know what I mean sometimes I
check it out and I just see what's going
on and I window shop but um remember
that song by 50 cent use the window
sharper that was the last song what 50
cent made were like okay well I guess
he's done making songs huh so so it was
like gangster it was like just like it
would be like a video god this is a
crass episode but that's what I saw she
would be like this is how you see it
would be like this is how you stack
[ __ ] and it'll be like three girls on
top of each other you know like like
there was anybody ever questioning how
do you stack [ __ ]
you know like anyone was ever like ah
[ __ ] I gotta go on Ask Jeeves calm how
do you stack [ __ ] Jeeves you just
pretty much probably put a [ __ ] lady
on a lady on a lady also why are you
doing it just on a [ __ ] step one get
a piano bench have one lady one lady lay
down and then another lady lay down and
then another lady lay down on her it
will be like it's just gangster dude and
they just put that on the internet like
they have no parents and then another
one will be like
you know we just walk like does this be
like a porn like we just want to make
you [ __ ] and to be alone I got another
girl with another girl and then just be
like and I'm just like god damn thats
gangster I have no problem with it but
it's gangster you know what I mean
so then I would like but it's like oh
and then but the funniest [ __ ] to me was
she was like I saw one tweet where it
was like man they deleted no [ __ ] I've
seen a lot of actually seen a lot of
like girls where it's like oh I can't
believe a deep deleted my Instagram porn
stars I get it but some regular chicks
will be like ah I can't believe they
deleted my Instagram yeah [ __ ] stop
stacking [ __ ] you know what I mean
stop being so gangster with your mean of
course they delete it or how about you
see it girls Instagram it's like deleted
at sixty thousand but I'm back stop
exposing your meat dude what are you
doing man cover up your baboon Rutter's
Seacrest
I gotta think at different words dogs if
I keep saying put it's too much if I
keep saying the P word you know but it's
just uh
of course they deleted it stop being so
gangster dude oh man so funny dude
that's so funny to me man why do they
delete my Instagram bruh
are you really [ __ ] a skin dude stop
being so [ __ ] this is you this
because this is you on Instagram dude
just [ __ ] squirting all over stop
squirting if I worked at Instagram
I wouldn't delete the porn stars I would
delete the girls who are trying to get
away with everything to sell a watch or
to sell a [ __ ] bang energy drink or
whatever it's so funny that day that's
so funny to me dude this is a McDonald's
you know put your [ __ ] meat away um
yeah dude but shout out to that that's
the thing man I love people who love
their work I don't care if you're a
[ __ ] porn star or a [ __ ] UPS
driver you know that girl loves what she
does and she's gangster on Twitter cuz
you can be but just don't you know I
guess if you're a porn star or whatever
just do Instagram like more artistically
or whatever I mean because then I was
thinking about it and I was like maybe
it's more like me that's like saying
don't do jokes on Instagram like then I
wouldn't even have Instagram
maybe that's what it's like being a porn
star it's like well I can't [ __ ] -
what [ __ ] is what I love is showing my
taint you know
this is the song that I was trying to
play when at anytime a porn everytime a
porn star starts an Instagram when she
was deleted at 60k stackin um yeah man
I'm a man that made me laugh though
listen blue apron
nothing says summers finally here like a
classic juicy burger or whipping up a
fresh tomato salsa or sharing a
delicious meal alfresco this season
experienced the joy of cooking something
new trying new to you techniques and
making cooking fun again with blue apron
sounds like ages 8 and with an
ever-changing mix of meat fish and
vegetarian recipes to choose from it'll
be your tastiest summer yet blue apron
helps me discover my inner chef chef and
learn new recipes and techniques and
have fun doing it I actually cook using
blue apron and I've never cooked before
so turns out I really I like it it's it
they make it easy but it's also fun but
it's exposed me to like really cool
recipes that I wouldn't have even
thought to try which is probably the
coolest thing about it it helps make
cooking at home a sustainable part of my
weekly routine upcoming meals include
seared steaks and green beans fresh
basil fettuccine a sweet pepper focaccia
pizza spiced chicken and saffron rice
salmon and avocado rice balls dude rice
balls are get out of here they're so
good to start making delicious brag
worthy meals at home without the hassle
try blue apron check out this week's
menu and get $60 off when you visit blue
apron calm / Congrats that's blue apron
calm / Congrats blue apron a better way
to cook ah me undies
is here to change your underwear not
literally well it's here to change the
way you think about it they believe on
these shouldn't take themselves too
seriously
I do too you ever see somebody with like
underwear that they're real serious
about and
trying to be so sexy about it that's
absolutely not cool that's not cool
let the underwear speak for itself and
have a fun time with it they believe
undies should be soft me undies fit
every booty like it was made for
everybody and offer fun patterns that
give you the freedom to express yourself
it's very nice and very fun and very
cool new women's products by me undies
me undies also believes that every woman
should have the freedom to wear whatever
cut they want and whatever color that
they want and whatever size they want so
ladies rejoice the feel free collection
is here me undies size tested with me
undies size tested these 5 new
silhouettes on every body type with an
ultra soft feather-light waistband that
provides zero restriction those these on
these will be the best thing that has
ever been on your body
offered in sizes extra small to 4 XL
different they got the new feel free
collection offers an ultra soft
waistband that maximizes comfort with a
waitlist feel designed with you in mind
they drop the new prints drop every
Tuesdays so uh none the exhaustion begun
they don't just have one diesel though
they also have super soft and comfy
onesies and loungewear perfect for
lounging um yeah I love my me undies man
I wear them all the time they're very
comfortable they're way more comfortable
than regular and wear I don't know why
other companies aren't doing it but
they're not me undies has a great offer
to my listeners for any first-time
purchasers you get 15% off 15% off and
free shipping that's a no-brainer
especially because they have a 100%
satisfaction guarantee so to get your
15% off your first pair of free shipping
and a 100% satisfaction guarantee go to
me undies comm / Congrats that's me
undies comm / Congrats Buffy makes
bedding that is earth friendly and
cruelty free
we've spent sleepless nights worrying
about the impact the betting industry
has on environments on the environment
so we decided to change it our products
are made using only sustainable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed and that's really cool we need to
start thinking about the planet
Buffy's latest product the breeze is a
comforter made entirely from 100%
eucalyptus fiber to regulate temperature
and keep you cool and comfortable all
night long the breeze regulates
temperature no more night sweats get
cozy without overheating it's a really
great comforter man your boy Dahlia uses
it it keeps them cool good for the
environment but also keeps them it's
it's just it's just right I would say
why not choose 100% plant-based bedding
that's better for you and the earth you
know it's like it works the best anyway
it's a very nice comforter you might as
well do your duty and help this world
that we're trying not to ruin buffy
offers a free trial you can try a
comforter in your own bed for free if
you don't love it return it at no cost
for $20 off your Buffy comforter visit
Buffy CO and enter code Congrats that's
$20 off your Buffy comforter go to Buffy
dot co and enter congrats
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash app the official app of the log
cabin cash up keeping the log cabin
going to Chang because we don't deal
with paper in the log cabin we're not
going to do that we're gonna deal with
the cash up only yeah it's amazing when
you look at the internet how many people
get pissed off and daily about things
I've thought about when Twitter started
and stuff like how annoying it would be
and just like the white male bashing
which you know is so weird but like the
Tarantino thing was the craziest to me
like when they were like what was I I
heard an article about it or I read an
article about it and it said once upon a
time in Hollywood this is bond and this
is on nbcnews.com
think opinion analysis essays hot take
hot take you know don't say your own
thing is a hot take by the way
for other people to say a [ __ ] hot
take you know hot take my ass it says
once upon a time in Hollywood this is
the title once upon a time in Hollywood
takes the Sharon Tate murders and makes
them about men come in Tarantino's new
movie reframes a brutal crime is a story
about white male heroism that does a
disservice to both Tate and to the story
dude KITT and this is written by a guy
or girl oh [ __ ] look it's written by a
girl so yeah I didn't see the movie but
you literally it's a the movies about
what it's about I I don't even know how
to explain this to a [ __ ]
thick-headed person the movie isn't
about the Sharon Tate murders if it's
not about the Sharon Tate murders okay
it's about what it's about
so I mean how do I say this and not make
you seem like a [ __ ] idiot a movie is
about what it's about
it's not about what it's not about
you're getting mad that once upon a time
in Hollywood is not about the Sharon
Tate murders is getting mad at the movie
Transformers that it's not about the
Sharon Tate murders in the right way
because the movies just about what it's
about so I don't I I can't explain how
you that's it that's it you go like that
like we were in a court of law and they
were like well we you know we're really
looking into this [ __ ] forensically
about why this the white male made a
movie about the Sharon Tate murders and
it's not about the Sharon Tate murders
then I come in with my business suit
because I'm a lawyer and I say well you
see movies are about what they're about
and then the [ __ ] judge goes okay so
George Bronk and everyone goes yeah
that's true
and look at this
leave it to Curtin Tarantino to make a
story about the murder of Sharon Tate a
truly horrific real crime in which
female cultists murder a famous pregnant
woman that revolves around men also what
about Quentin Tarantino who made Kill
Bill Vol 1 & 2 that's about a chick I
mean dude this is just outstanding this
article this fucked-up dumb [ __ ] article
here's the thing too I tweeted about it
it's so crazy how many people look I'm
in Hollywood I'm a Hollywood guy but
it's so crazy when I tweet something
like that the traction it doesn't get
because people are so so scared to even
like something negative about something
about this article because then they're
like well I don't to be racist or
whatever the [ __ ] it is you're getting
mad at the wrong [ __ ] dude
Quentin Tarantino is in a bad eye he's a
bad guy he's not a bad guy I don't know
this [ __ ] doesn't mean he's a bad guy I
mean them look at this for the most for
most of the film Tate and Samantha
family girls our sideline seemingly so
the real stars this is an excerpt from
the thing for most of the film tape and
some Manson Family girls are sidelined
seemingly so the real stars Leonardo
DiCaprio and Brad Pitt can do their
thing yeah yeah how about this yeah
they're the two biggest oh you mean the
two biggest hey you don't have to put
them in you know about real in quotes do
you know why because they're the real
stars of the movie because that's what
the [ __ ] movie is about
that's what the movies about stop
[ __ ] complaining this article is why
Trump's gonna get elected again
I mean it's so [ __ ] funny and then in
the middle of says want more articles
like this sign up for the think
newsletter and get updates on the week's
most important cultural analysis oh dude
I want more taints like this eat it look
at this
but Tarantino isn't interested in who
Sharon Tate was anyway all he cares
about is what she represents a sex
symbol a woman cut down in her prime I
didn't see the movie so I can't speak on
that um it's so funny man the [ __ ]
people like this is an article dude
imagine if I was this famous as famous
is something that these people will just
destroy me how much should I say that's
a [ __ ] quote unquote problematic it's
so weird to me hot take what does hot
take me bad take I for real okay
catch you later whoever wrote that hmm
no I know how a hot take is but it's
usually a bad take you know I saw a
tweet that was like I camera what show
it was but it was like hey they
cancelled Netflix canceled this show but
sure give Eddie Murphy's seventy million
dollars to [ __ ] make a special okay
companies could do whatever man they
just do what they want you know
McClane about all you want but it's like
the internet man it's the best and worst
huh
innit it's so [ __ ] crazy I got to see
that movie though it's three hours long
movies that are three hours long or just
too long huh just like I'd go see a
movie that was 50 minutes it's like even
comedy specials like I did I'm gonna do
that's why I did that half-hour
comedians of the world won I was like
alright maybe this will be the new thing
to do and you know I'm doing my hour
again I'm doing another hour for Netflix
but like I just want to do like a 45 50
minute one
I feel like [ __ ] in hours long I used
to open up for jo koy he used to do two
hours he would kill the whole time but I
was just like aren't these people
[ __ ] tired I don't want to do two
hours at a certain point it becomes an
ego thing not maybe not two hours but
like I remember [ __ ] somebody was on
stage at the Laugh Factory I can't
remember if ship I think Chapelle did
like a long was just [ __ ] around on
stage for a while and then I think I
think Dane did like eight hours or some
[ __ ] on the stage of the Laugh Factory
like what are you doing that's so long
it's always sad at a point at a certain
point not two hours but like some guys
will do like three hours it's like what
do you live go do a life
I know that's not the norm he doesn't do
eight hours all the time but like
obviously it's just like I don't know he
was going through some [ __ ] yeah I think
right now if I ever do eight hours on
stage I'm going through some [ __ ] I
didn't want to be on set for eight hours
yeah let's see I mean dude between the
army hammer sucking a kid sucking his
toe thing and then the [ __ ] Quinn
Tarantino thing that just was like
hilarious to me like that this [ __ ]
Internet what this world's just going
nuts
III II it's weird when I'm like how I've
been I've been on set all day every day
and I just like it's weird how like you
can just I bet if you have like a real
job like my job is not a real job doing
stand-up like I'm traveling I'm doing my
show for an hour I'm doing two shows
sometimes an hour each for a night and
then the rest of the day I can do
whatever I want so I know what's going
on in the world but I wasn't really
doing that like we're so hot I mean my
[ __ ] outfit for the movie I'm not
really checking my phone and I'm just
kind of like I don't know what's going
on in the world so I feel Dumber like
actors or can like they'll will get you
gotta like I mean let me tell you the
did think about the movie taken that
badass [ __ ] movie that I loved and
Liam Neeson's one of my favorite guys
okay think about how much of it is
actually him doing something like they
have to set up so you shoot like a page
like - a page a day or something or two
pages a day three four or five pages a
day sometimes or if you're really
crunching it you do like six pages a day
or some [ __ ] in a script the script is
120 pages in taken I'm sure it's a big
budget so they were doing not that many
pages a day but a scene you will shoot a
guy walking and putting his keys down
turn on the TV that scene from start to
finish will take like three hours to
shoot it so Liam Neeson for three hours
is walking into a door into a room
putting the keys down turn on the TV and
then they go okay cut we got to change
the light that guy camera Liam's taller
than the thing and we got to do that we
got to make
sure and then maybe Liam Neeson's like
oh that doesn't work that doesn't work
for me I need to walk in and put it down
with my left hand so then they're like
oh [ __ ] we gotta film it from this side
so now that scene takes three hours if
you if that's your job you're and you
don't do anything else you're dumb as
[ __ ]
I'm not saying Liam Neeson's dumbest
[ __ ] he probably reads or [ __ ] you
know this is the podcast I don't know
what the [ __ ] he does but like if you're
just like the past week I've just been
sitting on set doing and I'm dumber I'm
[ __ ] Dumber I have to read a book out
of my book in LA I gotta get a new book
but I'm dumber because I've just been
sitting around in the [ __ ] desert
I really feel dumb dude you ever have
those days where you just feel [ __ ]
dumb there's like a cloud in your
[ __ ] head that's how I feel I used to
call them wax paper days it feels like
there's a piece of [ __ ] wax paper
over your face that's how I feel but I'm
still here for you guys mostly because
of the money though at this point you
know they became very lucrative this
podcast so but I do really love you guys
well I really like you guys you know I
don't want someone to stab me because if
they I said I'd love to them and they're
like are we married stalkers are nuts ah
stop
you know some people like DM me over and
over and over and over and over again
just talking about anything just like a
lamps like for real and I'm just like
and I don't really read it but I'm some
every now and then I'll click on one and
I'll scroll and this person's DM to me
50 times or more and they're talking
about things that I don't give a [ __ ]
about and I'm just like ah what do you
think this is here are you a fan or are
we got the energy that goes into that
huh
crazy I've had people email me every day
for years I don't know how they got my
email i [ __ ] block him it's [ __ ]
scary out there dude I'll I I read this
book I was nervous about this person
once I read this book the fear the gift
of fear by who's it by and it's so good
man this book is so good it's about you
know stalkers and how it reads like a
thriller but it's an actual serious like
it's a real it's nonfiction and and it's
about how like when you know somebody
when somebody's like giving you because
sometimes people will like call people
and be like I'm watching or whatever the
[ __ ] it is or like they'll you know that
make up dummy internet accounts and they
like try to scare you you oh you know if
it's in it's like you know who it is the
whole thing is is like you know who the
person you're that is stalking you is
you you just don't realize you know who
it is which was like the craziest [ __ ]
that was like the wee-bey meme and then
I thought about and I was like I know
what the person who's doing this is
because it was under a dummy account I
was like oh I know who this person is
and I figured it out and then when I
figured it out I I did my life the way
Gavin de Becker I get I'd lived my life
in defense of that and the person
stopped that book is so smart I can't
recommend it enough even if you don't
have stalkers it's a good thriller read
but who doesn't have stalkers nowadays
this is the internet if you're a chick
and you don't have a stalker you just
don't know you have a stalker
here we go another opinion that's gonna
piss me off let me click on it oh these
boy they do try to this clickbait this
hot hot teacher The Lion King has a
great new Beyonce song the rest of it is
trite and uninspired nothing about
Disney's latest live-action remake
really lets you feel the love tonight
people are annoying huh who the [ __ ]
would read that hey cats is gonna be
creepy as [ __ ] huh
how the [ __ ] are they gonna make a movie
cats they might as well like have you
seen the musical Cats oh my god dude hey
go [ __ ] yourself do you know why it's in
my trash can what they call them
Jellicle oh you're gonna make up a
[ __ ] word in a musical about cats
that sing dude hey Co [ __ ] yourself it's
so bad dude and then finally they go to
mammaries and I'm like alright cool and
then they the songs not even long and
I'm like this [ __ ] bro imagine an adult
for real going like this with claws they
make a movie about it let me tell you
right now right now the movie cats is
gonna eat [ __ ] in the box-office it's
gonna eat [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I'm telling
you right now
cats movie I know movies that are gonna
tank and and are not gonna tank by the
way I come to me Hollywood watch the
cats the movie trailer
sorry pee
I haven't seen the trailer yet so let me
look at it and then I'll let all that
you know if it's actually gonna bomb or
not this human cats you know other just
cartoons are the real people though the
cartoons one chance of course one chance
always a one chance in the judi dench it
looks like they're just wearing cats
[Music]
some of they just are they pretty much
still early to chains because they have
necklaces on and [ __ ] oh this will make
a lot of movie because it's [ __ ] just
kids bad
[Music]
that's weird azim
[Applause]
[Music]
attempts Gordon isn't it
jason Derulo's in it you just Albert
Jennifer Hudson moon in mckellen Taylor
Swift oh Jesus rebel Wilson what Sammy
Davis jr. Jesus Christ
who's gonna Bobby
movies gonna Baja
Oh nobody's gonna see a [ __ ] movie
about human cats dude that's so creepy
nah nah I know what movies are gonna
[ __ ] bomb what is another movie that
was of course gonna bomb oh what's that
movie and I like these actors too
I don't know I don't want to make enemy
more [ __ ] enemies you know there's a
movie out there that was gonna bomb so
bad you should have known and they
should have known why are they making
these [ __ ] you know dude I [ __ ]
wash my hair in two days and how many
days do you guys [ __ ] I want to know
you tweet me how many days you go
without washing her hair and tweet that
to me and then I won't read it cuz I
don't give a [ __ ] you know people don't
like tweet me about the thing let me
know what's your craziest workout people
on Instagram they'll be like do you ever
put [ __ ] walk around the house with
mismatched clothing on let me know you
ever we're [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] at home
what the [ __ ] how crazy but relatable am
i you don't talk about the real [ __ ] you
think you ask them on the [ __ ] you
don't talk about the real [ __ ] you're
not being relatable you're a [ __ ]
dude get out of here this [ __ ] all the
all things are facade I'm gonna start
believing them because I'm gonna start
believing in every conspiracy dude
conspiracies computers conspiracy
theorists why do they have to believe in
every conspiracy why is that the thing
the is there a conspiracy theorists out
there that just believes in [ __ ] 1 or
2 it's always like 9/11 not to [ __ ] the
government's big brother [ __ ] that
happen and this happen chemtrails all of
it
what's a call didn't really happen Sandy
Hook nobody leaves in just two
conspiracies you believe in zero or all
of them that's how you know cuz he's a
[ __ ] uh anyway
oh yeah like someone's mad that the
[ __ ] girls playing Harriet Tubman and
she's not an American she's a British
person that's crazy dude imagine being
in Britain will you they got to get an
American person if they were gonna do a
play about Harriet Tubman they gotta
[ __ ] get an American actor
you can play whoever you want you can
make a movie about not the Sharon Tate
murders you can make that movie if you
want how many groups do we have to check
with to make a goddamn movie how many
eleven how come nobody got mad at Jared
Leto for playing trans why nobody got
mad at that cuz it wasn't the time to
get mad right and then later it was the
time to get mad that movie was made now
everyone will be so mad at Jared Leto
that's how you know it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
play you ever I don't give a [ __ ]
he's a bankable star so he played that
role cuz he wanted to I don't know I was
gonna start [ __ ] dude so I could play
everyone alright I guess that's it huh
is that it we did an hour okay I'm done
dude but you know
I'm also sweating download the cash up
for free on the App Store or Google Play
market you could download my app I got
you know do that you could listen to me
doing the podcast live go to the merch
store Chris Lee calm and subscribe to
the YouTube channel rate review the show
videos podcasts go up a day after the
audio podcast coming to San Jose Vegas
Peoria Santa Barbara Riverside San Diego
Foxwoods Bethlehem Pennsylvania and
Rochester Detroit Christian calm
congratulate that's it right that's it
yeah that's it you guys are the best
thanks a lot guys remember to keep
stacking them [ __ ]
[Music]